معنى الان من انقره مراسله الجزيره فرح
الزمان شوقي فرح تبعنا معك منذ ساعات
المؤتمرات الصحفيه مؤتمر تلو الاخر نجمل
معك الموقف المتعلق باخر التحديثات
نعم ازدهار لكن قبل ذلك فقط اشاره سريعه
وزاره التعليم في تركيا تعلن تعطيل
المدارس في عموم تركيا ليس فقط في المناطق
المتضرره لمده اسبوع وهذا في الحقيقه ان
دل على شيء فهو يدل على خطوره الوضع
وتوقعات بارتفاع الاعداد بشكل كبير
بخصوص
اخر التحديثات رئيس وحده تقليل مخاطر من
من اثار الزلازل في اداره الكوارث هنا في
انقره اعلن قبل قليل عن ارتفاع عدد القتلى
لتصل الى ليصل الى 1121 قتيلا وعدد جرحى
بعد يقارب 8000 جريحا وابنيه انهارت
بالكامل عددها بات يقارب 3000 مبنى وحين
يصف هذا الزلزال بانه الزلزال الاضخم منذ
زلزال وقع في منطقه ارزنجان عام 1939 فهذا
ين لان الارقام لن تكون قليله خلال ساعات
وربما الايام القليله القادمه حيث تستمر
عمليات الانقاذ في ظل ظروف جويه
صعبه وفي ظل البرد واستمرار
العواصف
وموجه من تساقط الثلوج هذا ازدهار نستطيع
وصفه بانه احد اكبر التحديات التي تواجه
فرق الانقاذ حتى وان دار الحديث عن
الجهوزيه والتاهب والتنسيق بين كافه
المؤسسه المعنيه هذه المؤسسات ذاتها اضطرت
لقطع الغاز والكهرباء عن تلك المناطق وذلك
في محاوله لدرء اي مضاعفات او اي حوادث
اخرى قد تقع في المناطق
المتضرره هنا بالنسبه لكيفيه اداره هذه
الازمه يشكل هذا الامر تحديا هنا في
الحقيقه لاسيما ان هذا الزلزال ياتي صراحه
في توقيت سيء وفي توقيت كذلك ياتي في في
الوقت الذي بدات فيه موجه البرد في عدد
كبير من المناطق التركيه وياتي كذلك قبل
اقل من ثلاثه اشهر من الانتخابات الرئاسيه
والبرلمانيه التي كانت الحكومه تواجه فيها
عده تحديات اساسا لكن كيفيه ادارتها لهذه
الازمه ستضع امامها تحديا كبيرا خاصه وان
هناك عدد من الخبراء لطالما حذروا من وقوع
زلازل مشابهه ليس فقط في منطقه شرق
الاناضول وانما كذلك في اسطنبول حيث يتخوف
كثيرون من وقوع هزات وزلزل مشابهه في تلك
المناطق بخصوص الشمال السوري الرئيس
التركي رجب طيب اردوغان اكد بان الخسائر
هناك كبيره ايضا وبان التقارير ترد الى
تركيا وتؤكد بان تلك المناطق متضرره
للغايه ما يمكن ان تفعله تركيا في هذه
المرحله حيث حتى الان
الحديث من قبل المسؤولين عن انقاذ المناطق
التركيه
وانتشال العالقين من تحت الانقاد لكن
بالنسبه للشمال السوري على الاقل من
الممكن ان تفتح تركيا بوابه نحو مناطق
الشمال لارسال المساعدات التي ستاتي الى
تركيا والى سوريا على حد سواء مساعدات من
اكثر من 45 دوله عرضت على تركيا
تقديمها سواء المساعدات الانسانيه او
الغذائيه او تقديم جسر جوي
مشى وطواقم تساعد في عمليات الانقاذ اداره
الكوارث كذلك اعلنت عن وضع عدد من الخيام
في المناطق المتضرره وهذا الامر قد يكون
صعبا على المدنيين في ظل وجود موجه موجه
من البرد القارس واستمرار تساقط الثلوج
على تلك المناطق
ازدهار الهلال الاحمر ما زال يكرر
النداءات للتبرع بالدم وهذا كذلك يؤشر على
ان هناك
مؤشرات وتقديرات بان عدد الجرحى سيزداد
خلال الساعات المقبله ازدهار شكرا لك من
داخل اداره الكوارث والطوارئ التركيه اباد
في انقره مراسله الجزيره فرح الزمن شوقي